[Musique]
on
j'ai fait la connaissance de mon père
quand j'étais encore dans le ventre de
ma mère et je vais beaucoup de guitare
pour moi et chanter et lormont ps et
jean philippe marthély et je me souviens
quand j'avais 4 5 ans ben quand il
faisait des prestations que ce soit
zénith ou peu importe la prestation
qu'il avait avec kassav on me retenait
pour que je n'avais pas sur scène
j'avais une envie c'est d'aller firmi
choléra fille chante et on fait faire
mon show et parfois même conques
engagement de remédier à certaines
chansons qui modifiait puis fallait que
j'aille faire mon show mais tout est
infime donc c'est une y en a il y en a
des anecdotes ya énormément de choses à
dire et c'est vrai que parfois qu'on s'y
prépare et vise album avec hassan bien
des albums solo
j'insistais pour aller avec lui mais le
plus souvent y avait école donc il
fallait pas rentrer états et
donc je me cachais souvent sous les
tables de mixage pour qu'on ne me dise
pas ramassés lors il faut entrer dans
mien et voilà il ya tellement de choses
parfois quand il criait des albums il
écrivait des textes avec ma mère je
trouvais des petites idées voilà parfois
on me disait bien faire les choeurs
j'avais quel âge peut être
en ce 12 ans est invitée à faire des
coeurs et je trouvais ça tellement
magique
et si aujourd'hui je suis chanteuse
choristes interprètent en fait si je
suis là aujourd'hui c'est vraiment grâce
à lui c'est lui qui m'a donné envie de
faire ce métier avec passion et surtout
avec beaucoup d'amour et c'est vrai que
quand je vois tout ce qu'il a fait et
surtout quand il est sur scène et il
suffit qu'ils désamour voilà que que les
gens soient va se déchaîner et la foule
se lève enfin s'il sait c'est vraiment
des magic est aujourd'hui si je le
répète si je suis là c'est grâce à lui
c'est grâce à nous et je suis fier juba
de beau papa je t'aime et je te souhaite
une longue vie pleine de bonnes choses
et surtout bonne fête des pères
il